le football américain est méconnu du
grand public et fait parfois l'objet de
fausses idées pour y remédier pour cette
nouvelle saison les templiers
d'elancourt ont organisé une journée de
découverte le but en fait c'est de faire
découvrir en fait ce sport faire
découvrir les opportunités qu'on
pourrait retrouver en faisant ce sport
pour dire aux gens que si vous venez ici
c'est que vous êtes motivés pour pour
faire les efforts qu'il faut pour pourra
devait à l'équipe pendant la journée les
intéressés ont participé à une réunion
un échauffement en salle et une
découverte des différents postes sur le
terrain le club a tenté de faire
comprendre que chacun avait sa place
le football américain c'est ouvert à
tout le monde qu'on soit grand petit
gros ou minces c'est vraiment en fait on
va utiliser la force de la personne pour
le bien de l'équipe
ces échanges ont aussi été l'occasion de
rappeler les règles du sport un moyen de
rassurer les parents comme ces deux
cantons
c'est vrai que quand on parle football
américain on pense qu'on pense
la physique je suis dit que le foot que
le soccer qu'on le dise
et du coup et on attend de nous aussi
d'être assurée dans les règles j'ai cru
comprendre que les chocs étaient un peu
bannie il est possible d'intégrer les
templiers dès 14 ans ils ont engagé
cette année un préparateur physique
une arrivée bénéfique pour tout le club